although fans will have to wait almost a
year to see the batman set to hit
theaters on march 4th 2022
thanks to trailers and leaks we're
already getting a sense of what the film
would look and feel like
one of the latest leagues features paul
dayno's riddler who gets only a brief
appearance on the one
trailer for the batman that's been
released thus far the new image gives a
clearer look at how dano's version of
the riddler will be styled in the matt
reeves directed film
if the watermark on several versions of
the photo that are currently circulating
social media is to be believed
it may have come to us courtesy of
australian based filmmaker and content
creator ryan unicom
the original source of the leaked photo
is unknown at this time
but it seems to be part of a poster
calendar or other piece of promotional
artwork that hasn't been formally
released yet
in the freshly leaked photo which we
aren't going to share here given that
it's
well leaked and we're not getting in
trouble paul dano's version of the
riddler has his face completely covered
just like he does in the trailer for the
batman
he's shown wearing glasses and a leather
face mask with eye holes and the image
as a whole provides a much clearer idea
of how he'll present himself than the
super dark trailer did
the mask of beers have a flap for the
riddler's mouth that can be covered and
doesn't seem to be very high tech
instead it has a distinctly rough feel
as if dana's character sewed the whole
thing together himself
basically he looks like the machine from
the movie eight millimeter with glasses
and a velcro strip over the mouth
it's much different than the way the
riddler has been depicted in dc comics
before
in the comics the riddler has
historically been shown decked out in
shades of green
purple and black sporting over-the-top
costumes emblazoned with his trademark
question mark insignia
this is the look that jim carrey adopted
when he played edward enigma
aka the riddler a riddler wearing a full
mask that looks totally homemade
is a far cry from what fans are used to
seeing after getting a glimpse of the
leaked image
fans have expressed their excitement for
the approach that director matt reeves
appears to be taking with the batman
one fan wrote on twitter the zodiac
killer vibes riddler is giving off in
matt reeves of batman
is the exact reason why i know he's
going to blow our minds
another user added i have no issue with
the riddler's new look in the batman
2022
he looks frightening and iconic in his
own unique way
it's an intriguing reinterpretation of
this character
we've had plenty of classic riddler
looks on screen now so i'm fully
embracing this fresh take
the batman is set in the early days of
bruce wayne's time as a crime fighter
and protector of gotham
and dana's riddler is said to be the
film's main villain a serial killer who
begins leaving clues behind at the scene
of his murders the element of clues
makes the zodiac killer a fairly natural
point of comparison
for dano's version of the riddler for
those unaware the zodiac killer was a
serial killer who murdered seemingly
random people in northern california in
the 60s and according to the murderer
himself
70s he famously taunted the police and
newspapermen with letters and ciphers
one of which was only deciphered in 2020
it seems dano's riddler will do
something similar
in the trailer batman reads a cryptic
letter the riddler left behind on a dead
body
all are part of his love of riddles
right for countless fans this newly
leaked photo of the riddler's mask only
reaffirms beliefs that dana's riddler
will be one for the ages
one user wrote on twitter even though we
have to wait until next year
i just can't help but have the feeling
that paul dano is going to crush it as a
riddler and the batman
this could be potentially one of the
best comic book movie villains
another twitter user tweeted paul
dayno's riddler is going to be one of
the greatest comic book movie villain
performances
of all time mark my words back in may
2020 dano spoke to the playlist
revealing that he was excited about what
the batman could be
joking that he couldn't say much about
the film without getting in trouble
dana said i feel really good about it i
think matt reeves is the real deal
i was really surprised by his script
which i think is potentially
really powerful there's something fun
there in my character and in all the
characters
it's the kind of movie that we're just
desperate to share on the big screen in
a big way
it would be worth the wait it's going to
be really cool
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss
a single one
you